One of the reasons we use centralized
application stores for downloading our
applications is that we can trust the
software that's installed on that store.
If we install an application from a
third party website, it's possible that
that app could contain malware. And once
malware gets on your mobile device, it
does have access to quite a bit of data.
That's why a good best practice is to
not install APK files onto your Android
device. These are Android package kits
that contain the app itself. And if
you're installing from any source, it's
very possible that that source might
have malicious software. In Apple's
ecosystem, this process is a bit more
straightforward because the only way to
install applications is through the
curated Apple App Store. If you're an
Android, a good safe location would be
the Google Play or a trusted app store
instead of simply downloading any file
from any website. Installing these apps
from anywhere but the larger app store
is referred to as sideloading. And it's
this sideloading process that can create
problems for us from a security
perspective because we don't have as
much control over where those
applications are coming from.
One of the challenges with these mobile
phones is that a lot of the operating
system is hidden from view. There is a
little bit of information you can turn
on though using developer mode. This
turns on capabilities that allow for you
to debug using the USB connection. You
can view additional memory statistics,
and there's a lot more details and logs
that you can gather when you're running
in developer mode. If you have an Apple
iPhone or an iPad, then you'll need to
use the developer mode built into Xcode.
Xcode is the developer environment
that's available on Mac OS. So, if you
want to get additional log information
or more details about how that device is
performing, you will need a Mac OS
device that is connected to your iPhone
or your iPad. If you're on an Android
device, you can configure developer mode
on the Android device itself. You go to
the settings and about phone option and
from there you tap the build number
seven times. That is your secret access
into this developer mode. And you can
configure and manage the developer mode
from that same about phone screen.
As we've seen, these mobile devices are
very good at restricting our access to
the underlying operating system. But
some enterprising researchers have found
ways to gain more access to the OS of
these mobile devices. If you're running
on an Android, we often refer to this as
rooting. And on an Apple iOS or iPad OS
device, we refer to this as
jailbreaking, although these terms tend
to be used interchangeably. Whether you
are rooting or jailbreaking, you are
effectively modifying the firmware of
that device. You're overwriting the core
operating system with a completely
different operating system, and that's
what's giving you access to the
underlying OS. A device that has this
level of root access effectively gives
you complete control of that mobile
device. So, if you wanted to sideloadad
your own apps, you can do that on a
device that has been rooted or
jailbroken. And if you have this device
connected to an MDM, it no longer has
that MDM capability. It is now an
independent device.
Sometimes downloading an application
from a trusted app store isn't enough to
keep your system safe. There could be
situations where you might download an
app that looks normal, but when you
download it, it turns out to be an
illegitimate application. A good example
of this is the process that Google went
through in 2021 where they removed 150
apps from their app store. And these
were apps that did a lot of different
things. Some of them were photo editing
apps, some were games, some were QR code
scanners. One app called Ultima SMS
tried to subscribe users to a $40 a
month SMS service without the user
knowing that that was occurring. Some
attackers have even tried infecting the
development environment used to create
the applications. For example, there was
a malicious version of Xcode being used
called Xcode Ghost, which effectively
was malware that would infect its own
code into the applications built on
Xcode. A good best practice is to always
check the source of where that download
is coming from and to be very familiar
with the application that you're
installing on your mobile device.
Many of our mobile devices provide us
with a way to see how much data we're
transferring over our wireless networks.
And you can determine what applications
may be performing more traffic transfers
versus lower traffic transfers. If you
happen to see one app that's suddenly
using a lot of network usage, it may be
related to a malware infection. There
may be command and control information,
or perhaps the malware is proxying your
communication so that it can see into
your encrypted packets. Some of these
reports that you'll see in your mobile
device are very detailed and you can
break down how much traffic is being
transferred from different network
connections and be able to break this
down on an appbyapp basis. There are
also a number of thirdparty reporting
apps that can break down this for you in
a different form to show additional
graphs and metrics. And if you're not
sure if malware is your issue, it's
always a good idea to run a thirdparty
malware scan to see if it identifies
anything that might not be normal on
your mobile device.
When your mobile phone starts running
poorly, you can really tell it's not
responsive to pushing on the screen.
Some of the applications perform slowly,
and you can see the animations begin to
chop and slow down. Very often,
restarting the device will get the
device back up and running with very
good response time. And often, you'll
see there is an operating system update
or an update for the application that
might fix the code that's causing the
rest of this to slow down. You also have
the ability to close different apps that
are running on your mobile device. So,
you might be able to close things you're
not currently using and free up those
resources for other apps. And if this is
constantly occurring and you don't think
it's a hardware problem, you might want
to perform a factory reset. This will
delete all of the software on your
device, you're back at an original
starting point and then you can restore
the applications and data from there.
If you're on a different network or you
want to control how much information is
being transferred from your mobile
device, you might want to set an alarm
or alert that tells you when you're
reaching a certain threshold. If you're
on Android, this is a feature that is
built in. It's a data warning and limit.
And you can turn on this data warning to
inform you when you hit a certain data
limit over time. This is not a feature
that is available natively in iOS, but
there are capabilities in iOS to prevent
you from transferring large information
over a much slower cellular data
connection. This data limit feature in
Android allows you to receive a message
telling you when you're reaching that
upper threshold. So, if you are on a
limited data plan, you'll be able to
react accordingly when you start to hit
that threshold. This could also inform
you of unusual traffic patterns,
especially if a lot of information is
being transferred. So, if you have been
infected with malware, this data usage
limit may be the first notification you
have that something unusual is going on.
At that point, you might want to run a
malware scan or check into the
applications that you're using to see if
you can limit how much data they happen
to be transferring.
If the device you're using is not able
to connect to the network at all and not
able to download anything from the
internet, this might be something that
is malicious or it may just be a
misconfiguration inside the mobile
device. If it's malware, it may be
restricting your access to those network
resources so that you don't download any
anti-malware software. If you think the
issue is related to your Wi-Fi
connection, you could disable and then
reenable, or you could try turning off
all of the radios using airplane mode.
It could be that restarting the device
will resolve the problem. That clears
out everything that might be in memory
and starts your network connection over
from a clean slate. And of course, if
we're concerned about security, we might
want to run that malware scan to see if
something might have gotten onto your
system. If you're on an iOS device, you
can go to the transfer or reset iPhone
section and you can try resetting the
network settings and then reconfiguring
them to see if that solves your network
connectivity issue.
We get a lot of ads when we're surfing
around the internet, but you may find
that your phone is showing you a few
more ads than you might normally get.
This could be due to a malware infection
that is simply showing you ads that are
making money for the malware author.
Trying to remove ads from these mobile
devices has been an ongoing challenge.
For example, in 2019, an app called Ads
Blocker for Android promised to remove
all of those ads from your system. In
reality, this showed more ads on your
mobile device, but if you went into the
list of available apps to uninstall it,
you'll find that it wasn't even listed
on your system. This was part of a
strain of malware known as fake ads
block. And its goal was to show more ads
on the screen and make more money for
the malware developer. Ultimately,
running an anti-malware scan can give
you more feedback on whether this
application is one that is legitimate or
if it happened to be malicious.
Malware authors know that the easiest
way to get their malware on your phone
is to have you install the malware
yourself. Sometimes they do this when
we're surfing the internet and they find
a way to present you with a screen
telling you that you're infected with
malware, but all you have to do is click
this button to install a security
update. In reality, of course, you're
clicking this button and you're
installing malware. The challenge, of
course, is that many of these alerts and
warnings look very legitimate. and
someone who's not familiar with this
process might easily click that button
to install the security update and
immediately they're now infected. Once
this malware gets on your system, it can
start asking you for additional access
to your email, to any files that you may
have stored, or anything else that's on
your mobile device. These warning
messages themselves are relatively
benign. You can simply close the window
and there's no harm done to your mobile
device. But if you did happen to click
the install security update button,
you're going to have to either delete
everything on that device and start from
scratch or find a way to remove that
malware from your system.
In many cases, the folks that are
developing the applications for your
mobile device are different from the
people that are manufacturing your
mobile device. And for that reason,
there could be inconsistencies on how
these applications perform between one
device and another. Many of us have
experienced an app that is working
normally and then suddenly closes with
no warning. Or it starts having very
long delays when you're trying to use
the app on your mobile phone. Or it
could be that there are features in the
app that you're trying to use and those
features aren't working for one reason
or another. And it could be that when
the app is running that it's drawing a
lot of power and using up all of your
battery. In all of these cases, the
problem is probably related to the app
itself. So, you'll want to contact the
developer of the application and
download the latest version of the app
to see if these bugs have been fixed in
the latest version. Many of us have seen
instances where private information has
been leaked onto the internet for
everyone to see. Sometimes this is due
to a data breach on your mobile device.
You may want to run an app scan or an
anti-malware scan to see if something
unexpected is running on your mobile
phone. And if you think your device has
been infected or has been breached in
any way, you might want to perform a
factory reset and perform a clean
install of your operating system. This
will certainly remove any malware that
was there previously and leave you with
a system that is a fresh install. And it
may be that all of this data that
somebody has gathered is not directly
from your phone, but is from the
cloud-based resources that you use to
store this data. So, if your data has
been breached on the internet, make sure
you check your iCloud or Apple
Configurator login, your Google
Workspace login, and change any
passwords you may have associated with
your Microsoft One Drive. You might also
want to consider adding some
multiffactor authentication to any place
where you're storing information in the
cloud.